let me pull up the story from Yahoo news
it's a story originally from The
Advocate Bud Light pledges 200 000 to
support lgbtq plus business owners of
color they also recently sponsored a
pride parade
I got I'm just gonna say this outright
if a company is seeing a 30 drop off in
sales has fallen from the number one
spot to number two has seen a stock drop
off of 27 billion dollars that's billion
with a B
and then they double down that's not a
business I'll tell you why that's not a
business because a business is trying to
produce a service or product and sell it
to people
Bud Light is an advocacy Institution
I I think two two important things I
think America uh American first legal
I believe it is I'm not entirely sure
someone is saying if you were a
shareholder contact us this looks like a
very serious violation of their
fiduciary duties to their shareholders
you may have a legal case I will also
say
well there's two there's one other thing
I want to add to this but the first is
this is this company in my opinion is
probably going to collapse into a
certain degree if they keep doing this
you can't like they're really crossing
their fingers that Bud Light as beer
will do better than like they like they
don't need it to be a company anymore it
is now be they're hoping that it is a
solidified entrenched institution that
can never be dismantled too big to fail
then they can wear it like a skin suit
and use the money you buy for beer to
support a cult
think about that Bud Light is not a
business it is funneling your money into
a cult despite knowing it is destroying
their business it's because they don't
care when the brain slug latches onto
your skull does the brain slug care
whether you live or die that's obviously
brain slugs aren't real my point is
whatever strange creature has gripped
Bud Light it doesn't care if it if it
sucks the the innards out until it
Withers into a husk and collapses
because it is extracting the resources
from this once Great American
Institution
they know they're collapsing their
shareholders know it's collapsing Bud
Light does not care yes and I know why
there's a name for that slug it's called
CEI it's C HRC is that slug that's using
CEI because Bud Light just lost their
perfect CEI score which feeds into their
Dei score like last week their ESG score
I have a viral tweet about it actually
it's got a 35 000 likes on it so I'm
just going to read that it's titled why
is everything gay buckle up because
we're going down the gay Rabbit Hole the
CEI is the corporate the corporate
equality index
it is a woke credit score that judges
companies based on how many woke issues
they're posting and then to get ahead of
it I said well what is woke because
that's always the question well you guys
don't even know what that means it's
like yeah it's the it's a presence we
all know what it means but it says the
words co-opted from the black community
by gender activists and it's been
infected with this cultural War it's
been affected with neo-marxism that's
what it is so who made it up and who
gives the score so from my understanding
it's the Human Rights Campaign HRC sends
lobbyists to these countries and it
gives them a list of these demands and
if they do not comply with these demands
then the woke investors put pressure on
the boards activists are mobilized
advertising campaigns are shut down they
lose their funding they lose their
investors they they get threats so
anyone who continues to do business with
them these people they get penalized as
well anybody who does business so so
who's funding the HRC there's a lot of
different ones and two of them are um
through George Soros companies the first
one's the open Society foundation and
the other one is like the George Soros
Foundation or something and this is
something you can vet you can look it up
right now so who runs the open Society
Foundation then I wrote uh oh definitely
don't Google that because we're not
allowed to talk about that guy he's the
one we shall not talk of
uh so essentially if you don't if you
don't get a good score the lizard god
king of the world doesn't let your
business exist
um so this fake score is everywhere it's
controlling everything it's it's
coercion and this is the despotic rot
that is light doesn't care about their
business so I there there's there's
nothing
but light doesn't care about making
money yes
so so what so what is happening now is
it's demoralization it's part of that
denationalization thing that I was
talking about earlier this is the
demoralization process so what they do
they they they take an American
institution like Bud Light like Target
like Walmart and they like Tim had said
they infect it with this brain slug now
the idea is that people are just going
to accept that that's what they want you
to believe like no we're just going to
do this this is the way forward we're
going to accept that but that's not the
truth as you can tell by the stocks
dropping and how much money they're
losing people aren't just accepting that
so that means that it it it's uh an
American institution is going to fail a
prestigious American institution going
to fail before our eyes it's going to
demoralize the country and that's that's
what it is it's Belgian now it's owned
by in the ab inbev which is a Belgian
company so they essentially sold out I'm
trying to find out when Budweiser sold
out to the belgians
um I can't find a year but it's not an
American company anymore it has the red
white and blue uh Allure has the red and
white logo and the Bud Light as the blue
and white it's an establishment it's at
every fourth of July picnic you know
it's it's Memorial Day it's an American
institution like an American icon that
they're actually just taking they're
just gonna take it down belgians are
using I'm not blaming all Belgian people
but this Belgian company is using it to
to trick people into giving them money
to impact and invest on whatever they
want but they're letting the Budweiser
brand fall apart right now they don't
care you're right they don't care
because it's a b in Bev it's worth
probably a thousand times what Budweiser
itself is worth or something I don't
know what the exact numbers are but it's
just a drop in the bucket of their of
their total brand I think people need to
understand it the the Constitution is
meaningless to a culture that does not
care for the Constitution yes it can say
whatever it wants it can say all of
these really great things and if the
people behind what's happening with Bud
Light and young people when they get
older if they are the dominant cultural
Force you will have soldiers in your
homes you won't have guns you won't have
speech you won't have a right to a trial
you'll go to a trial and and they'll say
man you're guilty because we said so
look at look at Donald Trump being found
criminally liable of a 30 30 year old
insane insane story about how he went to
a clothing store and had sex with a
woman and then she was like oh he found
we found the one dressing room that was
open and then he had his way with me or
whatever and it's just there's no
evidence there's there's no logic to it
Trump at the peak of his Fame walking
with no security into a heavily
populated department store and nobody
notices or says anything no one comes up
to him and then he finds an empty room
like the story is completely insane but
they still said yep confirmed you like
we are we are inching towards this point
look at the January 6 defendants there's
a guy who's on video who's talking to
the cops
smiling and nodding his head and then
ushering people out of the building a
proud boy he got 12 years in federal
prison even though he was helping the
police they don't care they will lie
then you will be like well I'll I'll go
to trial and then the jurors are all
going to be sitting there waving their
cult flags and they're gonna be like we
don't care what the Constitution says we
won we will lock you up and the cops
will come to your house and say I have a
First Amendment right to speak and
they'll be like none of that matters
anymore and then they'll crack you the
trunch and throw you in the van yeah the
problem with the U.S Constitution is
it's not adapted to the age of the
Internet it's it's still reliant on
before no that has nothing to do with
what I'm talking totally does because
mob mentality can spark overnight now
with the internet and that the
constitution can't stop it and no
Constitution can stop but literally
nothing but something that prevents at
least prevents people from
um controlling social media can allow us
to stop it but if we can't stop social
media from muting our conversations then
no one can stop it so we need free
speech in that we need these systems to
be free and open so that we can organize
as the Constitution intended for us I I
agree to a certain
I I agree I agree to a certain degree
but the issue is
when the left started encroaching and
enforcing these things people on the
right said I'm so scared please just
leave me alone and they they did they
did nothing very few people I mean a lot
of people did don't get me wrong Trump
obviously rose up he got elected
but I can't tell you how many look Bud
Light they only lost 30 percent of their
sales there are still people who will
drink Bud Light or other a b inbev
products there are still people on the
right who who aren't going to do
anything and they're going to be like
I'd rather just keep my head down and
not say a word and so long as so it look
the problem is not that evil exists it's
that good men do nothing yeah yeah I
think people are waiting for someone
else to fix the Constitution right now
and I like I'm open to Rapid adaptation
but I'm also very concerned about rapid
adaptation I don't want anybody in I I
don't want to see another Amendment
added by this Congress like
even I'd even be worried about
um the Article 5 States uh convention
like at this point I just I don't trust
anybody there's so many Communists
infiltrated into the government that if
they added another amendment God knows
God knows what it would do I I just I
believe the way forward is the tenth
amendment I believe that the way forward
is like you know like the courts that
are corrupt those those courts are in
New York those courts are in DC you know
they that's there's a Stranglehold there
on these corrupt courts I worry about
what happened to Donald Trump because
they could they could do this Justice
Kavanaugh now they could make him guilty
Bud Light needs to collapse it's a big
ask but Bud Light needs to collapse
completely to the point of it being a
non-existent product
so that a message is sent that there is
a red line that we will not cross
otherwise they can capture institutions
and then gut them strip the resources
and people keep buying it and they will
just use it like a skin suit yep well I
was going to ask you do you think that
there will come a point where
but Anheuser-Busch is realizing that bud
light's just draining everything and to
get rid of this they just cut Bud Light
loose close the brand and then just move
on with something else they'll still
produce Bud Light but under a different
name not not by choice yeah once it's uh
dead it's it's dead yeah if people don't
buy it at all and so we're hearing more
and more and more that people are not
buying it sales are down 29.5 that that
is insanely massive that may be getting
to the point where it's not no longer
profitable to produce well it and it's
no longer profit well and then it will
take a turn when you know BlackRock and
Vanguard don't have enough money to
support these industries so I'll I don't
know like Anheuser-Busch obviously Bud
Light is the biggest well then not
anymore they're not number one Modelo is
not number one in the United States
which is huge great but let me tell you
I love that we we we're making this
coffee over at caspro and it is very
very difficult we've invested a quarter
million dollars to start we actually
started with a little bit less and then
we keep having to put more money in when
we sell a bag of coffee we do make a
profit but then we have to reorder that
bag and we have to recycle the profits
because we sold out so quickly we have
to order more coffee the next time which
consumes all the profits plus more
I would love to get to the point where
we could sell cans of cold brew all over
the country the issue is that producing
canned liquids you need to order a lot
of it you know we had Seth weather this
year he was saying no you couldn't do it
less you could do it cheaper
every company we've talked to about
production distribution sourcing and all
that stuff they've basically said it'll
come out to about five bucks for a can
and I'm like that's crazy like that's a
lot and I understand you go to the gas
station it might be like 3.99 for a can
of cold brew as it is and the reason
they get the like Star Wars will get
that cost down is because they'll make
50 million cans or maybe not 50 but like
10 million cans and then they if they
make 10 cents per can they're going to
make enough profit for it to work for
them but for us we cannot produce enough
of this to to uh get the price down that
low
you make a million cans and you make a
dollar per can you get a million dollars
profit you can reinvest thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time